a texas national guard soldier is feared
dead after risking his life and jumping
into the rio grande to save illegal
immigrants
who we now know were drug smuggling
suspects it's a story you've seen here
but likely nowhere else as the
mainstream media has largely ignored the
story former u.s border patrol chief
rodney scott is here to react
rodney it's so great having you here
today um how good morning how
frustrating is it for you to know that
really outside of fox news and some
conservative media outlets virtually no
one has covered the death of this hero
i think one outlet one mainstream media
outlet covered it for 22 seconds the
rest zero
it's extremely frustrating it's
demoralizing to the to the border patrol
agents that are down there the national
guard the texas dps
and it's really frustrating the local
community members i've talked to a few
this last week even in as far as new
mexico
and the lack of coverage the lack of
caring
is just mind boggling to most and uh you
know biden city is going to have a more
humane border this is not more humane in
any way shape or form
no there is nothing compassionate about
this policy
at all um
now we're hearing that this soldier
actually saved drug smugglers and that
is the issue here that we don't know
who's coming across um these the border
and so many times they're saving
children they're saving pregnant women
they're saving young young and old men
but this in this case we're talking
about drug smugglers
yeah i think it really highlights the
complexity of the border you know some
people want to talk about the border and
only show pictures and call people
asylum seekers they show the families
coming across but the entire border is
controlled by the cartel nothing crosses
that border without the cartel
controlling it and agents have no idea
who they're encountering until actually
they have hands on
and that our borders are completely and
totally out of control now we keep
talking about this this wave of
migration of title 42 goes away that
wave is already here and there's
criminals and there's terrorists mixed
in our nation's uh at risk and nothing
stays at the border it's going to the
town where the your
viewers live in right now they go
everywhere and the biden administration
just ignores it and then doesn't even
have the
courtesy to acknowledge the death of the
soldier
no it's unbelievable especially when you
look at the amount of time we've talked
about this this morning ronnie the
amount of time that was spent on
a false story about border patrol
whipping uh haitian illegal immigrants
it turned out to be false they never
apologized the administration for that
and now we see this absolute ignoring by
the present by the biden administration
and democrat lawmakers in general of
what happened to this poor soldier i
mean
do we know you know his
his kin has been informed do we know
anything further about this are they
just still searching for the body what's
the latest
the latest information i have from texas
is they are still searching i'm not
directly involved in the notification so
i won't go any farther with that i do
know that both texas dps and the
governor's office the national guard
office is heavily involved
but i don't have any other follow-up
information on that this is just this is
another travesty that could have been
prevented if we would to just continue
to secure the border like we had in
every prior administration that this
this administration just completely
walked away from america walked away
from border security
yeah it's an absolute tragedy there's no
question about it and as you rightly
mentioned we have flights that were
going out just yesterday in the middle
of the night dropping people off all
over this country with no with no
information being given to mayors or
governors of of who and what it's done
undercover
meant to be away from the eye of the
public so clearly they know the public
doesn't like this but they're doing it
anyway and now we see this this this
horrible horrible tragedy well we will
honor that young man and until we find
his body we'll be praying for him and
his family and we thank you rodney scott
for joining us this morning and bringing
attention to just the lack of respect
especially for law enforcement who
defend our borders
thank you appreciate you guys have a
good day